[Music]
if anybody knows how to start a party
it's my brother Andrew
or should I say The Jig conductor
it's fine it's so cute it's so good no
Mom if anybody sees that I'm gonna get
put on a watch list
I can't believe college is over you have
a job nowhere we're not allowed to talk
about jobs at the five minutes of party
so you either don't have a job or you
have a bad job how much does a party
starter get paid I wonder
I have a bad job yeah
I mean I'm not just saying this because
I'm your mother I feel like you're way
ahead of the game
who's that that's a mom and her kid
did you two dance we're not feeling that
right now how about I bet you 300 I can
get her on the Dance Floor I will give
you a thousand dollars
[Music]
town
she really likes you I really like her
tonight is the night that you and Lola
danced your booties off
oh I don't know how to moonwalk
do you think he would be a good sitter
for you I do not do well with sitters
I think it might be a bit different with
Andrew do you want to meet my hamster
yeah I want to thank you for being so
kind to Lola the easiest thing in the
world I'm having more fun now than I did
the whole night
[Music]
dear husband I have fiance I hear you're
a great party starter I hear you're a
great professional lawyer
we'll figure out after college
[Music]
bring your heart to somebody is the most
perplexing thing
you can't just decide that you love
somebody yes you can no you can't yes
you can
we don't need you to babysit anymore why
lots of reasons
I'm drunk right now son everything is
just some vets
it's on me do you believe in soulmate I
think we all have
me soul mates for you like four how many
do you have like 1200
foreign